you know how the right loves to talk
about triggering the Liberals owning the
libs and it's all extremely childish and
unproductive when it comes to furthering
political discourse I agree with all
that and yet I still find it endlessly
entertaining to see Donald Trump so
easily triggered by reality including
the reality of his terrible and diving
opinion polls and his plummeting
approval rating so let me set this up
for you so that we're all on the same
page presidential approval presidential
approval absent flows it rises and falls
and very often it will find kind of a
relatively predictable range over longer
periods of time like a year or a
presidential term except when really out
of the ordinary things happen so like
9/11 under george w bush was one of
those extraordinary and and unique
things that can shift presidential
approval outside of its normal range so
ABC Washington Post recently released a
joint poll on approval rating for Trump
and it once again shows that recently
Donald Trump's approval is falling
people really think the guy is genuinely
doing a bad job in a number of specific
areas including the economy trade and so
on and Donald Trump erupts on Twitter
yesterday and today claiming that this
is something even that lawyers maybe
should be involved in because it's
another one of these fake polls that
Donald Trump gets extraordinarily
conspiratorial about and goes into these
unhinged tweet rants where he seems to
be completely disconnected disconnected
that is from how polls actually work
here is Donald Trump tweeting yesterday
quote ABC Washington Post poll was the
worst and most inaccurate poll of any
taken prior to the 2016 election when my
lawyers protested they took a 12 point
down and brought it to almost even by
election day it was a fake poll by two
very bad and dangerous media outlets sad
these complaints are so flaccid so
feeble so
puny and fragile that only the most
uninformed and intellectually
insignificant followers could possibly
fall for this stuff the polls are fake
this is the most inaccurate poll
everything is always completely
hyperbolic and unbelievable from this
guy and the truth is there's nothing
controversial about this ABC Washington
Post poll it shows the same thing that
most serious polls show it shows that
Donald Trump's high approval during his
term was about 44% pretty normal for an
unpopular incompetent president in our
hyper partisan environment and on the
downside the Donald Trump approval
rating sort of has bottomed out at
around 37 38 % and that's where it is
right now it has steadily dropped over
the last several months to 38 percent
this is not a rare or unusual low point
for a totally incompetent president in
once again a hyper partisan environment
where something like 20% of the
population will always say they support
the president you've got another 815 who
will be sort of on and off about
approving of the president and there's
just nothing remotely hard or difficult
to believe about this Trump ranges from
about 36 37 to 43 44 in all serious
polls lately there are recession fears
there's the China tariff stuff there's
the Alabama Sharpie Fiasco which is just
embarrassing so Donald Trump's
embarrassments continue and polling is a
little bit lower what is there even to
disagree with here and then Donald Trump
this morning continuing the onslaught of
just erratic tweets a brutal assault on
the English language that that Donald
Trump has been participating in four
years now saying quote in a hypothetical
poll done by one of the worst pollsters
of them all the Amazon Washington
post/abc which predicted I would lose to
crooked Hillary by 15 points how did
that work out
sleepy Joe Pocahontas and virtually all
others it's so hard to take this
seriously would beat me in the general
election this is a phony suppression
poll meant to build up their Democrat
partners I haven't even started
campaigning yet and I'm constantly
fighting fake news
Russia Russia Russia look at North
Carolina last night Dan Bishop down big
in the polls wins easier than 2016
Donald Trump would be more popular if he
just got off Twitter and was less
visible it's sort of like the referees
in sporting events if you're talking
about the referees that's probably a
sign that the referees are causing
problems for themselves in the same way
if you don't notice the referees you
probably default to their doing an okay
job officiating this game in the same
way if you're aware of Donald Trump
erratically tweeting about this that and
the other thing all the time it's not
helping Trump and when you look at the
Russia probe if Trump had just stayed
silent on Russia not tweeted about it
not attempted attempted to obstruct all
the time it would have gone much better
for him so here's my question to you am
i immature
for finding Donald Trump being so easily
triggered to be hilarious I'm a regular
critic of the way in which political
discourse has devolved in course and I
want depth I want to talk issues I want
to deep propagandize media I mean all of
it but at the same time when I see Trump
triggered so easily daily like the guy
has the thinnest skin I find it
hilarious ly entertaining tell me if I'm
a bad person because of that tell me if
I'm immature I want to hear from you I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and the
david pakman show is also now on twitch
at twitch.tv slash david pakman make
sure if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription to subscribe with twitch
prime to twitch.tv slash David Pakman it
costs you nothing but it supports our
show and that's where I will be
streaming commentary live tomorrow
evening of the third 20/20 Democratic
primary presidential debate we will see
you then and also back in a couple of
minutes with much more to discuss today
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me
who love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's B Li
NK is t.com /pa ke ma n